was shot in the People's Republic of
China
it's the bold lustful tale of a young
girl in her giant octopus just kidding
lavish and scope it tells a two story of
a boy of three who becomes emperor of
China and whose life spans the history
of his country from feudalism through
World War two and Beyond it's entitled
the last emperor
you look like you're enjoying this oh
very much
and I think it's wonderful that the
Academy would nominate a Chinese film as
Best Picture
yep we Americans are famous for our
open-mindedness
gentlemen I don't think los Emperor's
consider just a Chinese film why not
well the studio was American the
director was Italian and the producer
was British and we have a score was
composed by a Japanese a Chinese and an
American rock and roller that's true so
so our movie would be actually with
Universal No it's Columbia okay so we
give the award okay
the nominees for achievement in
documentary short subjects are Frances
still of memoirs of a bookseller Deborah
Dixon producer in the wee wee hours
Frank Daniel and Isaac been mere
producers language stays it all
Megan Williams producer silver into gold
Lynn Miller producer young Ned heart
sue marks and Pomona Kong producers and
the winner is young at heart sue marks
and Pamela contra deuces
just tried to make a little film that
said it's not only okay to grow old but
that it can be wonderful to grow old we
think come compo our cameraman Jeff
Jones our wonderful sound man and Larry
Marshall our cinematographer and thanks
mom for being there a special thanks to
the stars of our little movie my daddy
who's right over there who just
celebrated his 87th birthday last week
Reba and who are stars you've been an
inspiration to us both on and off the
screen to my husband my best friend Hank
thank you for being there for me all
these years to the Academy who said yes
and who loved our film as much as we
love bringing it to you well from
Hollywood hurray for Michigan